Speaker 1: So I hate to break it to many of
the people in the audience who think that
just more guns in more places will make everybody
safer. But there was at least one armed officer
at the school in Uvalde, Texas, yesterday where
this horrible mass shooting took place. There was
at least one armed officer there who was unable
to stop the incident. Okay. So what Republicans
are now going to is no, no, no, no, this isn't
about guns or gun safety or whatever. We need
more guns in schools so that the teachers and the
administrators and the janitors and the whoever
can protect the kids. Let's go to some examples
from yesterday. This is the immediate aftermath
of the shooting in Uvalde, Texas. Asked on Newsmax
how he would deal with the school shooting problem
in Texas, the Texas attorney general, Ken
Paxton, said, Well, let's arm the teachers.
Speaker 2: As you well. No. The state of Texas
not a stranger to shootings that begin in schools
or wandering schools. I know your team has
dealt with this before. What were some of
the solutions? And I know that Governor Abbott and
Lieutenant Governor Patrick have also come up with
tasks for a task forces to harden these.
Speaker 1: Task forces and. Oh, yeah,
yeah. Guys, what about the guns schools.
Speaker 2: So they're not easy targets, easy prey,
target, crazy people who go nuts with
firearms. What what can you tell us has.
Speaker 1: Been remember crazy people who go nuts
with firearms? Well, I'd rather have crazy people
who go nuts with a knife than with assault rifles.
Speaker 2: That's just me talked about in the past
what has been implemented and what hasn't been.
Speaker 3: Yeah. Sadly, this has happened again
and it's a horrible tragedy. But the
types of things that we talked about
and I'll never forget it after the Santa
Fe, I was having one point eventually
making it more difficult for people
even to get in that point of entry,
make sure that they would, and having potentially
teachers and other administrators who have gone
through training and who are armed because.
Speaker 1: Teachers and administrators who
have gone through training and who are armed,
they're all on this bandwagon. Texas Lieutenant
Governor Dan Patrick went on Tucker Carlson's show
last night and said, Let's harden the targets.
Speaker 2: We can do a lot of things. And Texas
has done a lot of things after the Santa Fe
shooting. Obviously, we have to do more. We have
to harden these targets so no one can get in
ever except through one entrance. Maybe
that would would help. Maybe that would
stop someone. But it's really bigger than that,
Tucker. It's we're a core society. We're we're
a society that's just at each other's
throats all the time. And and and we're
better that we're better than this as a nation.
Speaker 1: We have to harden targets schools now.
They have to be hardened. And at least Dan Patrick
is getting at the fact that there is a cultural
component here, although he would say it's just
political disagreement. If the liberals would just
let us ban abortion and put guns everywhere and
make taxes on the rich zero, you always do. Well,
actually, part of the problem is the gun culture
of the United States. Radical Republican Texas
Senator Ted Cruz said, oh, yeah, you've got
to just arm the teachers and rather you've
got to you've got to have more armed cops there.
Speaker 2: We know from past experience that the
most effective tool for keeping kids safe is
armed law enforcement on the campus. You know,
inevitably when there's a murder of this kind,
you see politicians try to politicize it.
You see Democrats and a lot of folks in the
media whose immediate solution is to try to
restrict the constitutional rights of
law abiding citizens. That doesn't work.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And then lastly, a Newsmax
host named I believe this is Grant Stinchfield,
he says you've got to have armed good
guys at the schools. That's the only.
Speaker 2: Way. Well, folks, by now you've
heard about this animal that went in to Rob
Elementary School this morning in the tiny
collar border town called Uvalde, Texas.
This animal murdered 18 elementary school kids and
three adults. Now numbers keep rising. My heart
aches for the loved ones of all of the victims.
As I watched the media today play out, it's wall
to wall coverage of the shooting. They only seem
to talk about guns, deranged, violent individuals
and how we keep guns out of their hands. If you
want to save lives, you can talk about that. It's
important. But the number one issue that needs
to be discussed is how do you stop a gunman
the moment he comes calling? The answer is
secure our schools. It's still not happening.
And in my opinion, institute programs where
school faculty can carry in school after going
through in-depth training on a voluntary basis.
Speaker 1: Yeah. So listen, there are reports that
two Uvalde police officers and a school resource
officer fired at the shooter but weren't able to
stop him from entering the building. That's one
report we're still working on confirming that.
But at minimum, according to Eric Estrada
from the Texas Department of Public Safety,
there was at least the school district
police officer who worked at the school
and saw the shooter with a rifle, with body armor,
engaged the suspect and was unable to stop him. So
quite literally, there were supposed good guys
with guns there and they still didn't stop him.
Now, their reaction, instead of saying, well,
maybe the problem is how easily the kid got guns,
they say, we just didn't have enough good guys
with guns at the school. You essentially need an
army there. They will not stop until it is. They
would rather turn schools almost into like forward
operating bases reminiscent of the military rather
than restrict access to guns. And by the way,
the people now they're saying, let's give the guns
to the teachers. These are the same teachers that
for the last two years they've been saying
these are the indoctrination, these are the
critical race theory, teaching, irresponsible,
indoctrinate ers who are grooming our kids.
Those are the people that now they want to give
the guns to. It's whatever will justify keeping
as many guns as possible around. That's the bottom
line. The rest of the world looks at us like we're
insane. And at some point you have to wonder,
are we insane? When you look at correlation
isn't necessarily causation, but look at this
correlation between guns in mass shootings from
The New York Times. The U.S. has the most guns and
the most shootings. No one else is even close in
guns. No one else is even close in shootings. Now,
I concede we have a problem here with gun culture,
but the same people that want to keep the
guns around like that culture, so they're
not going to solve that. There is sometimes a
mental illness component, but the people saying
that's the problem don't want to fund treatment
for mental health. But might it not be worth
seeing what happens if we limit the number of guns
that are out there? And I hate to be so negative
and cynical, but if nothing was done after 26 kids
were killed in Sandy Hook in 2012. Is something
ever going to be done about this? I don't
know. I don't know. Let me know your thoughts.